I have a bunch of patients who are
waiting for it, right?
They've been approved—
They've not been approved.
They're waiting and hoping
to be approved.
These two doctors have
conflicting viewpoints
on euthanasia in their country.
I think Canada's approach to assisted
dying has been successful.
I am very concerned about medical assistance
in dying laws in Canada.
Euthanasia became legal in Canada in 2016.
They call it “medical assistance in dying”
or MAID for short.
Since then, the number of assisted deaths
in Canada
has risen to over 10,000 people in 2021.
That's more people by raw number
than any other country
where assisted dying is legal.
In 2021, eligibility for MAID expanded
to include people
who are not nearing the end
of their lives.
And starting next year...
that will include people
suffering solely
from serious mental conditions, too.
Our participants are here to engage in
a new kind of debate.
Yeah, that's where you and I
would disagree.
I know.
Where instead of fighting over
unvetted talking points...
we ask each expert to pick three facts
that their opponent would have to
concede are true.
Dr. Maher, do you agree that
these facts are true?
I do.
Dr. Green, do you agree that
these facts are true?
Yes, I do.
They'll present their facts and
they'll each get a chance
to respond with a footnote.
And after the fact exchange...
we'll also have four additional rounds
to further clarify their positions.
This is a fact-checked debate
about euthanasia...
in Canada.
Here we go.
In Canada
assisted dying is a rights-based issue...
resulting from constitutional court challenges.
The legalization of assisted dying
did not come about due to
voter initiated ballots, as happened
in some US states...
or because the government thought
it was a good idea.
Both of which can change with
shifting political winds.
Importantly, these court cases were
brought and won
by people with both terminal
and non-terminal illnesses.
It is true that court cases...
gave people who didn't have
terminal illness...
the right to have assisted deaths.
But one of the plaintiffs
in that key case...
Jean Truchon, who had cerebral palsy...
when he was considering
getting assisted death
what he said was that it was
the loneliness...
that was brought on by the pandemic...
that was leading him to
make that choice.
So I'm really concerned about
what that means
for people in Canada...
who will make choices to die.
Not for medical reasons alone,
or maybe not even primarily
because of medical reasons
but because of social reasons:
poverty...
isolation, loneliness.
That worries me a great deal.
Jean Truchon ultimately
led his challenge
to the new law for assisted dying...
because he was about to lose function
in his remaining limb.
That was his initial incentive.
Ultimately, this comes down to
a question of rights.
And who, if anyone,
controls our lives.
My name is Dr. Stefanie Green
and I'm a provider of assisted dying
in British Columbia, Canada.
I've always been taught about
the importance
of patient-centered care.
And I have found it to be
profoundly meaningful
to be involved at this time in their life...
and to provide and facilitate
their final wishes.
There are 15 countries that allow
some form of medically assisted dying...
Including ten US states and Washington, DC...
that allow people with a six month prognosis...
to self-administer a prescribed drug.
Canada is one of eight countries
that allows assisted dying for people
without a terminal diagnosis.
Next year, it will join most of these countries
in extending eligibility to people
whose only condition
is a mental illness.
In these countries, cases involving
primarily psychiatric conditions are rare.
In Belgium and the Netherlands...
they made up about 1% of all cases.
Canada's assisted dying laws
lack the safeguards that
other countries have.
There is no requirement
that all reasonable treatments
at least have been tried by the patient.
The doctors are able to
initiate the conversation.
There is no review process.
There's nobody looking to see
whether people in Canada licensed
to do this...
have in fact followed the law
and followed the rules.
Canada rejected paternalism in medicine
quite a few decades ago.
The Supreme Court decision states that a patient...
is not required to undertake medical treatments...
that are unacceptable to the individual.
We have long accepted that patients
can refuse medical treatment.
Even if the result of that refusal is death.
There's actually a very rigorous process in place
for this assisted dying model.
There's a number of eligibility criteria,
but once they are met
there are on top of that, a number of
procedural safeguards.
Of course, we're in complete agreement
that paternalism is not a good thing
and every Canadian is free
to make their own choices.
But when we're talking about assisted death
we're talking about choices made
at a point in time
when a person is profoundly vulnerable.
My name is John Maher.
I'm a psychiatrist with a community
mental health team
in Ontario, Canada.
My goal is to help my patients
live their lives the way they want...
and to do all we can to ensure
that mental illness...
and all that follows from that
doesn't keep them
from living full, rich lives.
There was an initial concern
that people would request assisted dying...
because they couldn't access palliative care.
But the data has put that fear to rest.
Over 80% of the people who receive MAID
in Canada...
are receiving palliative or hospice care
at the time of their death.
For those few who are not...
88% of them have access
to such care.
Compare that to the wider
Canadian population
and all causes of death
when statistics suggest
that only a minority of people
are receiving
palliative care before they die.
The data that you're referencing...
comes from the forms that are filled out
by the MAID providers...
and it tells us nothing,
nothing at all, about the quality
of the palliative care.
We also know from the data you're citing
that 21% of people who...
who received MAID had palliative care
for less than two weeks.
While it's true, we don't have
an objective marker...
for the quality of palliative care received.
What we do know from lots of data...
is that since MAID was legalized
in Canada...
we have a significant increase
in the funding for research for palliative care
and an increase
in the number of people receiving and
dying with palliative care at home.
The vast majority of people who
access MAID in Canada
are patients with a cancer diagnosis.
The next most common underlying
illness are end-stage organ failures.
So end-stage heart disease
end-stage lung disease,
end-stage liver disease...
and neurologic conditions,
they’re around the 10% to 15% range.
The wait times for MAID
in Canada
are shorter than the wait times
to get a lot of specialized services.
That might be pain clinics,
psychiatric care...
long-term care homes,
veterans’ benefits...
supportive housing, community-based care.
That's not right.
My job as a MAID provider
requires me by law to ensure
that my patients have been offered
the resources and services
that could potentially reduce their suffering.
I agree we need to
reduce wait times
but at some point when potentially
helpful resources...
are not reasonably available
we can no longer hold individuals hostage
to society's failings.
It seems to me that
the greatest failing
we're talking about here
is a society
that's willing to help its citizens die...
rather than provide the services...
that we know help,
that we know work...
that we know reduce suffering.
Killing people while
they're on wait lists...
is profoundly immoral.
National polls consistently show
that the Canadian public supports
assisted dying.
This includes people who self-identify
as religious and people
with disabilities.
These polls were conducted
before our law changed
to allow assisted dying,
in the first five years of legalized practice...
and in every year since the amendment
that extended eligibility
outside the end of life context.
Two polls that asked Canadians
about their views on MAID
for mental illness
came back with very different results.
One poll showed over 60% of Canadians in favor.
Another poll, one in particular looking
at MAID for mental illness
showed that only 31% of Canadians
support it.
I don't think Canadians have
a full understanding...
of what is happening.
But those organizations that are
focused on what's happening...
and drawing attention to it
namely the 137 disability organizations in Canada...
the national indigenous organizations...
the mental health organizations,
the United Nations...
everyone who is looking at this
and understanding
what is going on is gravely concerned...
about the discriminatory impact
of this legislation.
Canadians have been talking about
and debating
assisted dying since the 90s.
There are multiple reports,
multiple committees...
multiple news stories,
multiple court cases...
to suggest that Canadians are unaware
of what the issue is
is not exactly fair to
the Canadian public.
There is no consensus
among Canadian psychiatrists
on when any particular psychiatric illness
is incurable.
And under the law that comes into effect
in 2024 in Canada
a psychiatric illness must be incurable
and a person must be in a state
of irreversible decline.
But we can't say who that is.
Consensus in health care
is rarely required.
There is no consensus amongst doctors...
about whether they can
accurately predict
a prognosis of six months.
Yet it's an eligibility requirement
for assisted dying
in several countries, including
the United States.
However, in Canada, for MAID to proceed...
two independent clinicians
must be of the opinion...
that the patient's condition is incurable.
When someone has a terminal illness...
say cancer, we have
a pretty good idea...
of how long they might live.
May not be precise, but we have
a good idea.
In mental illness, we have no idea.
People get better after five years,
after ten years.
These are very, very different conditions...
very different circumstances.
Now, we'll move on to the additional rounds.
Questions.
Personal experiences.
Debunk.
Uncertainties.
Stefanie, can you ask
John a question
that helps clarify his position?
John, do you believe every person
with a mental health disorder
can be treated successfully?
Because if not and they have capacity...
should they not be allowed to access
the same legal health care
available to everyone else?
We both know the majority of people
living with mental illness...
have full capacity.
They can make their own
treatment decisions.
To answer your question,
can we treat everyone?
I don't think that's the right question.
The question is, can we
reduce suffering?
Can we help people cope
with suffering?
There are certainly going to be people
whose illness will not get better,
their physical illness.
But can we mitigate their experience
of their symptoms?
Can we bring support...
care, compassion, and love
to them in a way
that makes their life for them
worthwhile?
I'm not talking about denying anyone...
the option of choosing MAID.
To be frank, everyone can already
choose suicide.
What we're working to do is to ensure
that every person is treated
with respect, dignity...
provided with care and support...
that we know can help
reduce suffering.
Okay, John, would you like
to ask Stefanie a question?
Only one in three Canadians
have access to mental health care
who need it.
Only one in five children.
We know from disability organizations
across the country...
that disability supports are
completely inadequate...
to live a meaningful life.
People are suffering...
in ways that we can do
something about.
I'm asking you...
would you support providing MAID
to someone...
while they're waiting for treatment or care...
that could help them?
But it's down the road a bit.
I would happily stand with you
and call for our government to do better
than what it's doing.
I think it's a separate issue.
There can come a time,
on a case-by-case basis...
Every situation is individual,
every situation is unique
and every case needs to be
assessed in a unique way.
There may be a time
when a certain treatment
is available, too far away,
much too expensive, inaccessible to the patient.
In this case, we have to seriously consider
not holding them hostage to society's failing
and to consider offering MAID if it's truly what they need.
A tough situation.
I grant you that.
John, can you tell us something
from your personal experience
that has strengthened your conviction
on this issue?
As a psychiatrist...
who works with a community
mental health team...
supporting people with the most serious
mental illnesses...
We are becoming overwhelmed...
by what MAID has introduced...
into our clinical worlds.
I have patients who are already saying...
“I'm going to stop treatment.”
“I'm not going to keep trying.”
“I can die.”
Our efforts to help them stick with
the very challenging
and sometimes long-term treatment
required to heal and recover
is being undermined.
We're not just doing suicide prevention anymore.
We're doing MAID prevention.
I'm going to tell you about
a gentleman I’ll call Ray
who was 62 years old
with metastatic lung cancer.
And Ray had been asking for MAID
for quite some time.
And as he and I worked through
the rigorous eligibility criteria...
at some point, I was able
to sit in front of him
and tell him he was eligible
for this care.
And when I sat there and did that,
I saw in him...
a physical transformation, which I've learned
actually happens...
almost every time.
I saw his shoulders relax.
I think I saw him smile for
the first time since I'd met him...
and it was immediately followed by
an expression of gratitude
for the mere possibility.
He decided to proceed with MAID
and we held it not long after,
in the rooftop garden
of the facility in which he was living.
And as is required by law
I was seeking his final consent
before I administered the medication.
He was surrounded by his friends...
and as he gave me that consent
he reached out and grabbed my hand.
He looked at me and he said,
“I know this is going to
sound odd, Dr. Green
but I think you saved my life.”
And it reminds me all the time...
that for the people who actually need
and want this care
it is tremendously important.
Stefanie, what is one piece of
specific misinformation...
that you've heard about MAID
that you'd like to correct?
Recently, a number of eye catching headlines
have appeared in the news
about Canadians requesting
assisted dying due to the threat
of homelessness...
or the fact that they're
living in poverty.
And while it's true that
anyone can ask
for an assessment of eligibility for MAID...
and those unacceptable social inequities
might be contributing towards suffering.
The law is actually perfectly clear
and Canadians cannot access
MAID based on those factors alone.
John, would you like to clarify
a piece of misinformation?
Some MAID providers have argued that MAID...
for non-terminal conditions...
is not suicide.
For decades, suicide
has been defined
as taking steps to arrange
your own death.
Some have said that what makes MAID
different than suicide...
is that it's well thought out.
It's not impulsive.
But in fact, in one US survey of
over 1.4 million Americans
80% of people reported
that they thoughtfully planned
their suicide...
Which means that we have to consider
where it fits into all of our
suicide prevention efforts...
and whether it undermines those
very directly.
And now for a round called Uncertainties.
John, what is something
we don't know
about this issue that we need
more research on?
Canada currently collects data...
on the illnesses—
the physical illnesses that lead to
requests for MAID.
What we don't have is data...
that considers the socioeconomic reasons
people might request it.
And how significant an impact...
that might have on the request
and perhaps whether it drives it completely.
We don't know whether poverty,
homelessness...
being on a waitlist for treatment...
being refused disability benefits...
we don't know why...
people are choosing MAID
and we should.
On this point, John, I think we're
almost in agreement.
Canada has recently expanded
the type of data it's...
gathering on patients who
request and receive MAID.
And I'd be curious to see if it mirrors
what we know
from international jurisdictions.
Everywhere where this data
is collected elsewhere...
we know that it is the
socially advantaged...
who are accessing assisted dying
not the socially disadvantaged.
So I'll be curious to see
if that plays out
in the Canadian context, which is what
I expect to be frank.
That said, I think we do
have a good idea
of how people describe
their own suffering...
and therefore why they're requesting MAID.
Primarily, it's for people who can
no longer do the things
that bring meaning to their lives...
who no longer are able
to do what we call the
activities of daily living...
who've lost a sense of dignity
or independence.
And I think if we could find research
that would help us better understand...
what leads to that type
of suffering...
potentially there's a way
we can learn to treat it.
I'm concerned about this law...
having, I'll acknowledge,
the unintended...
but profoundly disturbing consequence...
of having people feel like
they're a burden
and that they should choose
death over life.
That they should no longer demand
of their government,
of their fellow citizens...
that care and support be provided.
Having spent time
with many suffering individuals,
I can tell you...
that Canadians are extremely grateful
for this option.
In a testament to the quality of care
being provided...
not a single person has been charged
with misappropriate action.
I think Canada's approach
to assisted dying
is more than adequate.
It is solid.
It is good, and for some,
it may be a model...
for considering care
in their own region.